Oh,
je sais que quelqu'un est à la maison, il y a un animal
qui possède un grand pouvoir spirituel
pour ne pas être mêlé à mes études.
l'entraîneur principal ici au
stade Shamu, elle a capturé ce que signifie être
un entraîneur SeaWorld, mais cela m'a fait
réaliser que ce qui lui est arrivé
aurait vraiment pu arriver à n'importe qui.
Je m'attendais à ce que quelqu'un soit
tué par tilikum.
c'est autre que c'était une erreur de formateur,
cela ne s'est pas produit par hasard, ce n'est pas un
événement singulier, vous devez revenir en arrière pour
comprendre que Misty a tous les deux entendu parler de l'
homme qu'ils pourraient simplement choisir les
jeunes, c'est la pire chose que j'aie jamais
faite
quand tilikum est arrivé à SeaWorld,
il était deux fois plus grand que le prochain Emma,
vons stocké ces baleines dans ce que nous appelons un modul
de 20 pieds de large et 30 pieds
de profondeur et les lumières se sont toutes étei
tes, ce que je pense est probablement  une
psychose toutes les baleines en captivité toutes
traumatisées psychologiquement ce n'est pas
que du silicium si vous étiez dans une baignoire
pendant 25 ans ne pensez-vous pas et devenez un
peu psychotique
Don vous dirait que c'était son
erreur ils l'ont blâmée c'est juste un
visage audacieux  mentir
j'étais juste l'instructeur pour se débarrasser
du jour où
l'industrie a tout intérêt à se
filer beaucoup de poupées Shambu elle
vend beaucoup de billets à la porte
il n'y a aucune trace d'un Norco faisant du
mal dans la nature
[Musique]